alors bonjour tous nos auditeurs il nous
internautes autour de la planète
bienvenue à tam tam canada qui
aujourd'hui va plonger en plein mystère
pour lever le voile sur la sphère la
question des vaccins contre la grippe
non seulement sont ils efficaces mais
est ce qu'ils arrivent à être
complètement inoffensif et beaucoup de
beaucoup de choses qui se promène je
parlerai pas de virus mais des histoires
qui se promènent sur le web notamment au
canada qui influencent beaucoup notre
réaction
notre réaction anti viral ou anti
vaccins oui le lendemain active anti
vaccins officiellement aux authentiques
des deux fois que je me suis vacciné et
contre la grippe
j'ai eu la grippe dès ma vie ici au
canada est bien est ce que vous dites
efficaces mais sont ils vraiment
efficaces ça dépend en fait de la souche
qui nous atteint cette année là ça
dépend de la nsa dépanner
al marri je me suis jamais fait vacciner
quand la dénoncer ça jamais est ce que
c'est parce que ces lentilles ou ceux de
l'ass aucun intérêt
non je suis pas tombé malade plus que
les autres d'ailleurs mais alors mairie
claude j'ai très rarement la grippe donc
j'ai jamais vu l'utilité d'un terreau
vacciner donc si vous êtes simplement
une personne en santé on attend une
personne qui est peu au vaccin ici at il
une personne par me levais vous si vous
éprouvez accès des lags les contre la
grille je n'ai jamais vu ça peut servir
évidemment les enfants très jeunes les
personnes âgées les gens qui ont des
problèmes de santé importants pour les
protéger mais si l'on parlait d'être des
vaccins de façon plus générale on va en
parler en musée moitié des missions de
cette affaire plus générale si vous
présentez d'accord pour le moment on
focalise sur cette guerre parce que 5
millions canadiens vont probablement
l'attraper cette année et voici notre
première question remue ménage donc
remuez vous les ménages et et on va
savoir qui est qui qui est le meilleur
aidé à vichy et les enfants à l'école du
pit s'exprime aussi la question du test
aujourd'hui zéro sur vingt est déjà pour
vous au caire si la question
marie-claude et les tanneries et paloma
et lugano la grippe dure à peu près huit
jours si on la soigne mais combien de
jours dure-t-elle si on ne fait rien
combien de jours durtal en moyenne si on
ne fait rien son conte traitement en
fait les plus forts c'est une semaine
cette semaine quand vous l'avez loi
borloo
après ils savaient ce n'est cette jolie
on peut commencer à travailler après us
et les sept jours marie-claude moi je
dirais que ces dix jours dix jours la
même chose c'est c 'est hui journal et
les femmes ainsi saleh les jours des
choses qui jouent à peu près aussi huit
jours voici la bonne réponse la grippe
ça dure huit jours si on la soigne une
semaine si on ne fait rien
ça vous fait dire ça m'étonne pas c'est
le célèbre humoriste français raymond
devos qui fait rire là dessus on a tous
donc en souvenir quelque part que tant
les parents aient conscience et de ce
soir là si vous le permettez je vais
vous demander on a invité mystère qui
est en bout de ligne ici quito sur le
skype de tam-tam canada avant de le
livrer ici tant titimal itunes l'image
de gros plans de notre île est d'accord
alors en l'accueillir je vais vous
demander quel serait un remède de
grand-mère favori pour combattre la
grippe que vous n'avez jamais paloma
remettre de grammaire tisane avec du
citron est dû bien exactement ce que
j'allais dire vieux c'est fantastique et
autres choses des capsules d'ecc menacé
et karoui qui n'a cessé très populaire
aussi rester à la maison
lehman a fréquenté le moins de monde
possible qui serait atteint du fameux
virus
écoutez on a invité un spécialiste ici
du québec le dr gaston de serres
médecins épidémiologistes nous a dit
c'est juste une histoire d'épicer
d'illogique
il travaille à l'institut national de la
santé publique du québec dr de serres
bonjour il a accepté sans délai
contrairement à skype de la commission
alors c'est fantastique
écoutez on a beaucoup de mythes comme ça
qu'on entretient beaucoup de croyances
et aussi à beaucoup de choses qui
circulent sur le web concernant les
dangers entre guillemets de ses
campagnes de vaccination contre la
grippe
dites-moi est-ce qu'il ya encore quelque
chose qui vous faire rougir de colère ou
de vous lever les bras en l'air on doit
ça n'a pas d'alluré en 2017 conduisent
encore des âneries au sujet des vaccins
contre la grippe
ici au canada je peux pas dire qu'il ya
des choses qui me fasse rire il ya
plusieurs choses qui ont été dites je
pense qu'ils ont de l'importance
d'abord il faut savoir que durant
l'hiver il ya beaucoup d'infections
respiratoires et quand on teste des gens
qui ont des
un tome de grippe dont qui font de la
fièvre qui ont mal à la gorge qui tous
et c'est à peu près le tiers de ces gens
alors on va voir la crypte vrai les
autres deux tiers c'est des gens qui
sont infectés par d'autres microbes que
le microbe de la guerre et donc quand on
dit j'ai reçu le vaccin de la grippe et
malgré ça j'ai eu la grippe
il faut savoir que souvent ce qu'on a
eue ce n'était pas la grippe est
évidemment le vaccin de la grippe n'est
pas efficace contre les autres virus
respiratoires alors le nom de ses deux
premiers c'est le deuxième point il ya
plusieurs personnes qui ont dit moi je
savais qu oui alors gelé la
communication oui vous êtes perdus
écoutez vous êtes capable de rétablir la
communication
alors oui on vous a perdu pour les 30
dernières secondes que disiez-vous
hochart spécialistes désolé je ne sais
pas si vous avez manqué la partie où je
disais que un tiers des gens qui ont des
symptômes de grippe
on est vraiment là maintenant ça on l'a
eu bon et l'autre partie c'est que un
adulte en général on calcule que le
risque de faire la grippe
et de cinq pour cent par année ce qui
veut dire qu'un adulte sur mail 5 pour
ça le différent à chaque année on va
faire un épisode symptomatique de grippe
à chaque 23
c'est donc c'est pas surprenant que
plusieurs personnes disaient je ne me
souviens pas de la dernière fois où j'ai
fait la guerre
ceci étant dit le vaccin de la grippe
comme l'audi une des personnes autour de
la table c'est quand même une catégorie
différente de la vaccination
pédiatriques donc levac ce qu'ont
annoncé les enfants sont très efficaces
92 95 pour ça est vraiment qu'à trop
peur du vaccin de la grippe
c'est une classe à part qui n'a pas du
tout la même efficacité que la
vaccination contre les maladies
pédiatrie nantes à ce niveau là les gens
qui sont des jeunes adultes en bonne
santé qui disent est ce que vraiment
pour moi le vaccin de la grippe c'est
important ben il faut voir que un adulte
qui va faire la grille pour avoir deux
ou trois jours on lit à faire la fièvre
avait mal par tour extérieur va tous et
pendant une dizaine de jours mais les
risques d'hospitalisation ou de décès
sont très faibles et ceci est très
différent pour les personnes âgées ou si
on prend les personnes de 75 ans et plus
qui constituent la majorité des gens qui
vont être hospitalisés ou qui vont
décéder de la grippe
ben pour eux la grille par des
conséquences beaucoup plus graves et
pour eux même si le vaccin de la grippe
est moins efficace que nos vaccins
pédiatriques
les conséquences sont tellement plus
grave que ça vaut quand même la peine
d'utiliser le vaccin docteur de serre
j'aimerais comprendre un peu la
situation particulière des canadiens
nous on vit dans des maisons renfermé
l'hiver comme ça entre nous tous un peu
comme des dans des igloos et je voulais
savoir ce qu'on a tendance à avoir plus
souvent la grippe que par exemple des
gens qui habitent tous un petit peu plus
au sud par exemple qui habite à
washington à la maison blanche
[Rires]
j'ai un peu mal pris de perdre par
exemple il ya de grandes différences
entre les pays sont tempérés et les pays
tropicaux dans les pays tropicaux haut
lieu de la guerre mais la grippe n'a pas
un aspect épidémique qui ressemble à
celui qu'on doit dans l'hémisphère nord
où l'hémisphère sud dans les pays
tempérés de ces deux hémisphères la peur
donc l'hémisphère dans les pays tempérés
bon avoir des saisons et puis des mecs
très marqué alors que dans les autres
puisqu'elle on la voit plutôt une
circulation à bas bruit l'homme et qui
va se prolonger par la démo ta paloma en
fait je voulais poser la question aussi
constamment c'est la distribution
géographique de la grippe parce que je
me souviens que au mexique
il y a eu
la grande et puis de l'épidémie de h1n1
je pense que c'était aux menaces annuel
des barrières non l'autre et après c'est
un autre type de glee et puis il ya eu
une grande épidémie pile beaucoup de
gens sont décédées au mexique
donc voilà je vais juste une question
concernant la distribution géographique
de ce type de grippe
est-ce que ça est-ce que la lame droit
à l'évidence oui la grippe dont vous
parlez c'est la grippe que eu lieu en
2009 donc la pandémie de 2009 a été je
dirais un peut pas démarrer mais
identifié et est le premier lieu on a
vraiment dit qu'il y avait un problème
c'était au mexique mais arrive à monter
des identifications qui avait été fait
en califormie donc est ce que c'est de
la californie ou du mexique que par la
grippe de 2009 il ya encore un débat là
dessus mais ça semble plutôt être aux
états unis que ça a commencé
ceci dit ceci étant dis donc
la grippe est une maladie qui circulent
dirais à large échelle donc le kansas et
que au canada aux états unis au mexique
ça circule à peu près en même temps on
n'irait pas russie et en chine donc
c'est vraiment mal a dit qu'il ya une
distribution planétaire et même si elle
est bonne différence de température par
exemple entre washington et new québec
on aura à peu près la grippe à la même
période d'acteurs dessin j'apprécie
beaucoup votre réponse à cette superbe
question moi j'ai répondu le plus
rapidement c'est sûr ça a une influence
au mexique après ça on après tout une
personne influente ça très sérieusement
je dois vous faire entendre parce qu'on
parle beaucoup de campagne sur le web
des campagnes virales contre les vaccins
j'en ai j'en ai noté plusieurs durant
notre recherche qu'on a effectué cette
semaine en préparation à cette émission
une envoyé par un homme est ce donc ces
voyous du web qui tentent de rétablir
le équilibre des fois aussi déstabiliser
les jours alors je n'ai pas passé de
propagande comme ça à l'antenne de
radio-canada ce n'est pas mon rôle mais
c'était mon rôle d'informer sur ce qui
se passe et j'ai possédé donc un petit
montage d'une vidéo anonyme
à écouter donc et professeurs professeur
vous êtes professeur quelque part mais
d'affaires de serre vous écouter ensuite
vous allez réagir d'accord merci
en écoute de nombreux experts médicaux
s'accordent aujourd'hui sur le fait
qu'il est plus important pour vous et
votre famille de vous protéger du vaccin
contre la grippe elle-même chaque année
l'industrie pharmaceutique
les experts médicaux et les principaux
médias travaillent dur selon jana tard
de se faire vacciner contre la grippe
non ne nous dit pas toute l'histoire ce
que nous n'entendons pas ce sont des cas
sur les effets indésirables ou sur les
produits chimiques toxiques comme nous
injecte pour lesquels les vaccins contre
la grippe sont plus dangereux que la
grippe elle-même première raison en fait
le vaccin contre la grippe en mai là
pour commencer
avez vous déjà remarqué comment les
enfants vaccinés tombe malade presque
immédiatement après une vaccination
deuxième raison les vaccins antigrippaux
contiennent d'autres ingrédients
dangereux tels que le mercure je n'ai
rien entendu aux mêmes raisons le vaccin
contre la grippe
berck spécialiste en immunologie
on a placé ou régulièrement le vaccin
contre la grippe a
alors que même les jeunes souffrent
bénéficier de vaccins contre la grippe
voilà c'est fait donc ça ce sera un
problème technique arrivée place une
prochaine permettent à nos invités
d'entendre sky pendant que simplement je
vous résume la sphère principalement il
y avait eu cinq arguments aux arguments
en fait qui donnait contre les vaccins
et 1,2 entre eux c'était que les gens
qui se font vacciner ton plus souvent
dans les jours dans les minutes qui
suivent même alors ayez aussi qu'il ya
du mercure dans les vaccins ou encore
qui a des échantillons de certains types
d'aluminium ou un dans les vaccins donc
d'aider des produits que les gens y ont
associé dans le passé à des problèmes de
santé très sérieux par exemple mercure
et alzheimer mais c'est pas un peu
normal qu'on tournait légèrement malade
après le vaccin puisque on s'est fait
inoculé le virus de la grippe docteur je
pense qu'il ya plusieurs éléments qui
ont été dits précise lydia les visites
d'un produit à base de mercure le
thimerosal est un produit qui est mis
dans les fioles de vaccin parce que
vraiment lorsqu'on d'entre une première
aiguille pour prendre une première dose
on peut contaminer le vaccin pour être
sûr de bactéries quatrième besoin d'un
agent de préservation et le thimérosal
et d'un agent de conservation dans
lequel ouvre une molécule de mai recul
c'est vrai la carte site de berthoud
lors qu'ils abattent bas elle est
vraiment infime
et quand on parle de maladies dues aux
intoxication au mercure donc lié à une
maladie qui s'appelle la maladie de
minamata on parle peu de quantité
semblable à ce qu'on donne sur une
baisse de l'action on parle de quantités
la mer des milliers de fois plus grande
que ça donc je pense que c'est certain
que quand on dit mon père que ça nous
fait
un peu tremblé où ça nous inquiète et
était évidemment quelque chose qui est
très important quand on parle de
d'intoxication la même chose pour
l'aluminium donc dans les vaccins dans
certains vaccins pour les enfin on dort
l'aluminium qui est un agent qui
augmente la capacité de notre système
immunitaire de détecter sur ce qu'on a
mis dans le vaccin pour monter une pas
eu de réponse immunitaire
là encore la quantité d'aluminium qui
est présente dans le vaccin elle est
extrêmement faible
donc je pense que ya du vrai dans ce qui
est dit mais il ya du flou dans
l'interprétation de ce qui est vrai donc
oui de l'aluminium
oui à du mercure non ces deux
composantes le sont sont pas en
quantités suffisamment élevé pour être
dommageable est ce que le docteur de
serre à cannes ni de vos appréhension
vos soucis vos préoccupations et vous
allez maintenant allez vous faire
vacciner mais en fait je voulais savoir
est ce que un peu tombés malades après
avoir reçu le vaccin quelques jours
après la ce que prétendent elles
anonymus bon alors je pense que les
vaccins ce sont des produits pour
stimuler le système immunitaire et comme
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure une par
une
ça va être de libérer ces mines
d'allibert des produits qu'on appelle
des cytokines qui mêle stimuler
l'apparition parfois de faire des fautes
de leurs musculaire etc cette année donc
c'est normal d'avoir une réaction après
le vaccin
même si la grande majorité des gens
vaccinés n'ont aucune réaction
perceptive des vrais mythe qui existe
c'est que lorsqu'on reçoit le vaccin
on va développer la maladie alors ça
c'est vraiment un mythe
le vaccin ne contient pas de vireux
survivants par les vaccins en injection
le vaccin en vaporisation qui est donné
surtout chez les jeunes enfants
l'union un virus vivants qui est adapté
à se développer uniquement dans le nez
donc on dit que c'est un virus
qu'on l'appelle adaptés au froid il ne
peut pas se multiplier ailleurs que dans
le nez qui ont une température qui est
inférieur à la température général de
notre cas donc il n'ya pas non plus de
virus qui va se répandre dans le car
aurait voulu donner la maladie on peut
avoir la malchance d'être vacciné puis
après avoir une grippe mais d'une autre
jardé grippe vrai problème c'est que le
vaccin qu'on a est un vaccin qui ça va
devenir une vidéo virale
[Rires]
donc il ya le vaccin de la grippe n'a
pas une efficacité très élevé ça varie
d'une année à l'autre on dit entre 30 et
60% des pendant des années et évidemment
sauce c'est beaucoup moins bon que la
performance qu'on a avec nos autres
vaccins donc à cet égard là c'est
certainement décevant de de se faire
vacciner et malgré tout de faire la
maladie et attend parlait donc de tout
votre groupe vous êtes déjà adultes à
qui apparaissait
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
le bénéfice pour vous de vous faire
vacciner si on souffre est vaccinée à
chaque année pour les prochaines années
vous allez réduire votre risque à peu
près de moitié donc au lieu de faire une
grippe en 20 ans vous allez faire une
grille par 40 ans bon c'est sûr le dit
comme ça c'est pas trop attrayant mais
par contre je reviens à l'exemple
initiale des personnes âgées si on parle
des personnes âgées lorsqu elles
attrapent la grippe
beaucoup d'entre elles vont aboutir à
l'hôpital et 5 à 10 % celles qui sont
hospitalisés vont être décédé donc là
évidemment on parle d'un danger beaucoup
plus grand et donc la recommandation
vise d'abord les personnes âgées les
personnes avec des maladies chroniques
sévères et et les faits les adultes en
bonne santé
là cette décision qui vous revient même
ce soit les animateurs de radio vous
faites ce que vous voulez aller renifler
il faut quand même dire que la
vaccination d'être est important pour
les enfants pour tous les enfants qui
suivent les douze je sais pas combien de
malades et des vaccins qui reçoivent je
crois que c'est fondamental de dire que
c'est important de les vacciner
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que j'ai
commencé en disant les vaccins et des
enfants c'est une catégorie tout à fait
différente à partir de catégories tout à
fait différente du vaccin de la grippe
ce sont des vaccins beaucoup plus
efficace pour des maladies qui sont très
sérieuses et donc clairement les vaccins
des enfants sont chaudement recommandée
et sans exception alors avant jusqu'à
quel âge d'aucuns savent à lui les
calendriers commence à partir de l'âge
de 2 mois pour les enfants donc
actuellement il ya des visites à deux
mois 4 mois 6 mois 1 à 18 mois il y en a
jantes risque à l'aréna en quatrième
année à secondaire 3 donc il ya
plusieurs bugs répartis durant toute
l'enfance et l'adolescence très bien on
va vous laisser partir vous êtes très
occupé jusque nous certainement vous
pouvez laisser rentrer votre fille a pas
de problème mais c'est fini merci
beaucoup d'acteurs d'avoir pris tant de
nous parler dr gaston de serres médecin
épidémiologiste à l'institut national de
santé publique du canada je mets du
médecin non non non écouter
inka quand on parle musée coach ça sert
à ranger sa faim médecins loger des
médecins surtout pas me faire vacciner
et je vous pour demander on va aller
rapidement vers un autre dossier qui
préoccupe beaucoup les parents partis
allemands au québec parce que c'est un
peu nouveau à grande échelle comme ça
mais ailleurs dans le canada aussi les
jeunes garçons les jeunes filles d'abord
qui ont reçu le vaccin contre le vph
donc donc une grande campagne qui a lieu
en ce moment par exemple au québec
beaucoup de parents qui se posent des
questions est-ce que je devrais je
devrais pas est ce que finalement ils
ont prend pas plus de risques que les
risques de maladies éventuelle de
contracter le cancer en raison de
relations sexuelles avant dans un jeune
âge avant l'âge de 19 ans je voulais
vous amener vers je veux faire un peu d
informations je veux dire que c'est à
des informations mais peut-être ces bons
textes c'est vrai le docteur michel
georget auteur de plusieurs ouvrages sur
la vaccination en france qui est à
l'antenne et tf1 des grandes antennes
qui fait le tour et on les écoute et
bien le message anti vaccins par rapport
au vph est peut-être que ça trouvera un
écho ici au québec
en tout cas il reprend des arguments qui
sont souvent déployés ici au canada on
va l'écouter donc dans cette vidéo
numéro 3 écouter les arguments contre le
fait de vagues se faire vacciner vos
enfants de 14 15 ans contre le psy plus
jeunes jeux alors voici ce qu'il dit une
partie de ce qu'il dit il parle
également
il ya des informations qui
n'apparaissent nulle j'ai trouvé par
exemple sur un site officiel du
ministère de la santé du canada que pour
les vaccins d'une façon générale et
c'est vrai aussi pour ce vaccin contre
les papillomavirus aucune recherche
concernant la toxicité sur la
reproduction et la toxicité sur les
mains ce qu'on appelle l'art pro
toxicité est bien né n'est requise pour
les vaccinations
or là nous avons affaire à des vaccins
qui touche la sphère génitale et ce qui
est à craindre c'est qu'on se retrouve
dans quelques années peut-être avec des
problèmes comparables à ceux qui ont été
engendrées par le distilbène
vous savez cette ce médicament cette
hormone de synthèse qui était prise par
les femmes il y a une trentaine d'années
pendant leur grossesse et qui ont
conduit à des cancers
pour ces femmes et surtout à des
anomalies génitales et à des cancers
chez la descendance
les filles de ces mères qui ont été
traités par le distilbène ont beaucoup
de difficultés ont eu beaucoup de
difficultés à avoir des enfants et on en
est aujourd'hui où la génération
suivante aux petits enfants dont les
filles et même les garçons peuvent
présenter des anomalies de l'appareil
génital et voir des développement de
cancers et on a donc là un exemple de
transmission à travers les générations
d'une toxicité des médicaments et il
n'est pas du tout impossible qu'une
telle toxicité soit retrouvée aussi pour
le vaccin contre le cancer du col
essentiellement c'est un argument c'est
qu'on prend beaucoup de risques pour pas
grand chose puisqu'il dit des
statistiques c'est le 20ème cancer
atteignant les femmes en france alors
qu'eux ont au stade 1 on peut guérir 60%
stade 2 40% au stade 3 30% au stade 4
20% et aux bus de la ligne peu de
personnes qui en meurent au canada j'ai
regardé les chiffres c'est le 20ème
cancer qui touche la femme
ça c'est pour le col maintenant pour le
corps du terrain c'est un peu plus
sérieuses et 8e cancer mais tout de même
au niveau des décès une femme sur quatre
sens
115 alors que le cancer de la femme
cancer de la femme cancer du sein oui
une femme sont en droit d'avoir et
beaucoup en décèdent
alors voilà ça c'est lui dix ans du
ministère de la santé du québec ni du
ministère de la santé du canada
donc il faut il faut être informé il
faut lire tout ce qui a à lire
certainement d'institutions publiques
officielles parce que sinon c'est la
meilleure manière de me alain fort mais
juste avant d'avoir un débat ici autour
de la table sur le fond et le compte de
ces informations qu'on peut capter comme
ça voici la version plus officielle et
gouvernementales elle viendra du canada
un reportage plus court que j'ai monté
ici pour faire entendre les principaux
arguments en faveur de la vaccination te
d'ivoire que c'est cissé sur le docteur
c'était noir ainsi tout blanc on écoute
aujourd'hui on peut lire ya pas mal de
parents inquiets à propos du vaccin
contre le vph un vaccin qui est donné
chaque année à des élèves à travers le
pays est-ce que ce vaccin
en amérique est d'abord est ce que c'est
vrai que le vaccin ne protège pas contre
tous les types de vph
oui c'est vrai parce qu'il existe une
centaine de types du virus du papillome
humain
le vaccin protège contre 9,2 cpp h est
ce que c'est vrai que des personnes sont
mortes après avoir été vaccinée la
compagnie muc a testé deux gros un
groupe avec le premier vaccin qu'elle a
développé le gardasil et l'autre groupe
avec le gardasil 9 chacun des groupes
le cinq personnes qui sont décédées mais
regardez les causes accident voiture
écrasement d'avion suicide hémorragie
cérébrale leucémie choc septique
blessures par balles
tu meurs manille à l'estomac mort
inexpliquée en aucun cas on était
capable de faire le lien entre les morts
et le vaccin bon et puis l'éternelle
question est ce que c'est vrai que ce
vaccin provoque beaucoup d'effets
secondaires une bonne respiration au
québec depuis 2008 sur près d'un million
de doses 330 personnes vaccinées contre
le vph ont eu des effets secondaires
inhabituels une réaction allergique par
exemple ou encore une rougeur sur la
peau si tu fais un petit peu de fierté
normalement donner du style in
l'organisation mondiale de la santé le
considère comme un vaccin extrêmement
sûre revoilà le pour et le contre et
vous êtes si vous avez déjà vu ce
reporter un jeune arrivant en fait
danser parce que je suis souvent ce que
fait la vie rythmée j'avais pas vu ce
reportage en particulier
alors c'est des arguments intéressants
là on voit que via une campagne virale
contre quelque chose mais là quand on
creuse on a le temps de creuser on a des
journées c'était jean professionnels qui
sont des artistes même creuset des
choses véritable ils obtiennent des
informations qui les gens qui ont eu des
problèmes sont décédées de choses à fait
contraire qu'il a le vaccin avec leur
mort
je viens tu entends délai la vidéo quand
c'est dangereux abandonné asie que
c'était neuf souche qui était atteinte
avec le vaccin
oui en fait sur l'excellent jeu oui mais
ce qui promet mais c'est qui provoque le
cancer utérus
c'est seulement 4 sél à 16 18 31 et 45
sont les responsables de pouvoir
développer une possibilité de cancer oui
c'est pas nécessaire que tu vas voir un
cancer comme toi ces cépages là mais tu
peux vous pourrez la voir alors ça
soulève des questions c'est beaucoup de
2,2 beaucoup de séries d'initiative
beaucoup d'argent dépensé beaucoup de
ressources mobilisées pour essayer de
2,2 contre est un problème qui est petit
plus petit qu'on le pensait initialement
on compte peu des fois le capter dans
des campagnes publicitaires et ça
soulève des questions bon si un vaccin
pour 6 ou pour ça ce qu'on doit tous les
prénoms mais l'essor je pense que les
vaccins il faudrait les prendre parce
que on parle d'eux est un cas dans 400
personnes mais quand même c'est
hennequin que les systèmes santé il faut
qu'ils aillent traités et ses
traitements
c'est pas si sharkey vacciner seulement
je pense que s'il ya une question
d'argent toujours le bain mais je
connais si on a trouvé un vaccin qui
peut peut-être empêché un cancer de se
développer
c'est déjà une grande réussite parce
qu'on n'a pas trouvé un vaccin qui
puisse empêcher le cancer du sein de se
développer ni d'autres dons sur vous de
tous les codes c'est exactement dans le
cadre du papillon mais à fès il ya
plusieurs cancers questions qui sont li
qui pourraient être évités pour être
empêché de développer et oui l'utérus le
col de l'utérus mais il ya aussi les
pénis il ya aussi d'autres parce que
maintenant on le donne ces mêmes vaccins
et aux garçons aussi parce que donc il y
a plusieurs
car ce qui pourrait éviter donc c'est le
pour et le contre qu'il faut les gens
sont capables d'évaluer les informations
on n'est pas là pour tous puisque
beaucoup de gens ne font pas vacciner
que ce soit le vph ou wpm plus tôt ou
d'autres ou d'autres maladies encore
beaucoup de gens qui ne font pas
vacciner lancé en france il ya quelque
chose de nouveau qui s'en vient la
france se sentent très souvent un peu
plus socialiste pour un peu trop mais un
peu plus socialiste maurice a poliment
la fille un peu plus socialiste que nous
au québec et des au québec on est très
socialiste perçu de la maison blanche à
washington par exemple alors en france
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
marie-claude déjà en france il ya des
vaccins obligatoires donc facile auto123
qui sont vraiment obligatoire contre la
diphtérie le tétanos et la poliomyélite
mais en janvier à partir de 2018 en
janvier cip en avant huit autres qui
vont s'ajouter donc coqueluche rougeole
oreillons rubéole est passé dans fait
tout ce qu'on fait pour nos enfants ici
mais oui c'est pas obligatoire on peut
encore y feraient peut envoyer une note
au grand je veux pas que mon enfant
voici la question question tam-tam
canada cette semaine d'autres y ont
répondu sur l'internet merci beaucoup
la france rend obligatoire en janvier
prochain la vaccination de tous les
enfants contre 11 maladie devrions-nous
limitée ou pas je vais on va se limiter
à quelques réactions d'autant plus que
les gens nous internautes se sont
limités seulement quelques réactions
zazie ou cinq habite ici au québec
imiter ou être conscient point
d'interrogation la question est ce qu'on
fait comme tous les autres on y
réfléchit d'abord mamies et les rames
elle dit non en lettres majuscules ça
veut dire en langage d'internautes niet
et puis françoise de par durand france
ça devient vraiment et demi qu'elle nous
avait pas écrit et elle réagit alain de
la grippe non d'autres thèmes chaussures
à la caisse quel type est préoccupé et
non elle était occupée à ses enfants qui
vont à l'école certainement un part de
ses gros enfin à chaque fois qu'elle
lequel le peu de madame depardieu alors
je suis maso bayeux a laissé les régimes
arabes
je l'imaginé avec la voix mais j'ai pas
l'accent je suis contre les maladies
mortelles par dj pas l'accent mais je
n'ai pas confiance dans les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques je pense que cette
mesure de vaccination obligatoire va
surtout profiter à l'industrie
la médecine se laissent acheter par les
laboratoires je n'ai aucune confiance et
elle poursuit en disant cela exigerait
une transparence totale sur l'efficacité
véritable de tous ces vaccins avec des
tests faits par des labos indépendance
selon moi je ne pense pas qu'il ya une
véritable urgence au niveau de la santé
pour nous imposer 8 vaccins obligatoires
supplémentaires
et elle conclut en disant je pense que
l'état répond aux pressions des labos
qui veulent faire encore plus d'argent
heureusement que mes deux gros garçons
de 16 et 17 ans n'auront pas attendre
l'épaule pour cette histoire la grisante
et tant que les deux gros bisous à l'ap
un gros bisou
on espère que les corps malade parce que
nous on n'a peur ni crainte de la france
la question quand même elle est sérieuse
est ce que il ya ces sous-entendus dans
sa dans sa réponse est ce qu'il y à des
pressions économiques da par des labos
pour vendre des vaccins au gouvernement
et le gouvernement dilma finalement si
tu veut nous vendre des vaccins pourquoi
pas nous on a de l'argent ça vient de
partout
la question est en droit de se poser
je suis poisson mais moi j'ai élevé
trois enfants j'ai fait vacciner mes
enfants ayant des boucs harnais dax
nation et j'ai toujours cru que c'était
obligatoire
je pose une question j'ai tout seul en
femme s'était divisée c'était vraiment
moitié-moitié ya des gens qui ne
voulaient absolument pas à les faire
vacciner leurs enfants et d'autres comme
moi qui me l'ont fait moi je vous
protéger les autres aussi dénoncé les
vaccins sauvent m2 qui vont à vis et des
maladies qui on connaît déjà qui
s'affaisse un tas qui ont fait des
vaccins oui parce qu'ils ont connu
mais ces vaccins qui y vivent une sortie
qui ne sait pas et parce que l'on en
parle des possibilités des problèmes
avec les le vph les vpn idps mélissa
secret on n'a pas des cas encore des
gens qui a pu les mener mais il n'y a
pas de cas suspect quatre cas suspects
en espagnol jusqu'à quand ya pas d icade
et qu'elle allait durer c'est un grand
débat cette aigreur débat c'est vrai que
les nouvelles les nouveaux accès pour
toutes sortes de questions je me suis
posé la question avec ma fille de 8 ans
qu'elle en est net des neuf ans que
l'année dernière a eu son vaccin pour le
contre le vph
sur le coup je me suis dit j'ai pas des
preuves pour dire que ce n'est pas
efficace
donc pour l'instant je vais te protège
et puis je veux qu'on protège les seuls
soucis au dos
autour de nous dans tous les faits il
n'y a pas de problème
je voudrais qu'on se quitte sur quelque
chose de spécial qui va nous ramener 100
ans en arrière presque maintenant sans
tendresse et de musiques typiques du
québec c'est bien c'est la première et
10 marie-claude merci beaucoup pour
cette semaine on va se quitter donc sur
ce mystère sont hors jeu sera bientôt
visuel alors leonardo gimeno merci
beaucoup merci et arrivons oui j'ai des
citations pour les deux prix remporter
votre équipe et du président
le prix du président de radio canada
pour l'inclusion parce qu'il était temps
d'inclure la parole autochtone à radio
qu'alcoa alors on est très fiers d'avoir
reçu ça c'est pas le briser le prix du
président américain on est fier de vous
non non non nous allons rester avec le
prix du président de radio canada il
subit c'est quand même ce à l'échelle du
canada
donc une personnalité publique
maintenant inquiète avec nous et puis et
jours plus tôt les navettes et d'accès
de la santé et pour garder et puis
paloma martino
merci beaucoup donc s'entend à l'arrière
et quelques poussières de -1 donc autour
des années fin des années 20 début les
années 30 vous là vous souvenez d'elle
c'est la première afin avoir envoyé des
fausses nouvelles sur le web ou enfin
presque
la bolduc qui chantait alors vous
devinez veut la grippe
[Musique]
on a une épidémie simplement de son bébé
y en a
dame est à lui on parle entre cette
année tous les matches sauf celle ci
pendant 52 lots et bons soins sais pas
d'où vient ce sont leur hymne de la
route